all right uh let's pivot over to the nfc
tampa bay buccaneers always entertaining
bruce arians this constant sense of
tension as it relates to him and tom
brady even though he tries to act like
there isn't and he hears aryans on
making halftime adjustments necessary to
eradicate a 17-point deficit that they
faced against the falcons on sunday
there's not a heck of what you do at
halftime but you can make those subtle
corrections
uh quickly and get everything done
um
there are times when you know you're
going to have time guys are just
hollering and uh
pissed off and there was part of it in
this one and uh
so it was uh
really really happy the way we made
those adjustments defen offensively and
uh and eventually defensively
yeah there was something else he said
yesterday about the struggles early in
the game is it an issue with the
scripting of the plays and he said it's
not the scripting of the plays it's the
execution
the latest little
little dart little knife little jab at
tom brady and the rest of the offense
nothing wrong with the coaching nothing
wrong with the plays nothing wrong with
the selection of plays the struggles
we're having comes down to the execution
of the plays i.e it's the players not
the coaches and that that
do you do you sense that's the issue is
it the players or is it still the
question of whether they're using the
players the right one no i i don't look
at it you know
again it's it's it's not a perfect game
you know the first half of the football
game yeah they were a little off there's
no doubt the falcons were getting good
pressure on brady and company you know
brady he felt a little uncomfortable the
one thing if there's a negative with
brady right now as we know is when he's
under pressure you know he he does some
crazy things with the football missed a
few wide openers you know a few open
receivers you know running back missed
the pass protection one play where you
should have picked somebody up on a
blitz and just let them go you know few
mistakes like that but
the big thing to to this is they did
adjust in the halftime but like subtle
to kind of what bruce arian said and
first thing that has to be said mike
and no no joke tom brady throwing the
football the other day on sunday was was
unreal i mean it was unreal it was very
very special his arm at 43
is still
so freaking good it's unbelievable he
never gets credit for how good and
gifted his arm is because he's a tall
big hand long arm guy and he could throw
the ball 105 miles per hour and you look
like it looks like he's only using like
70 effort but i was amazed with how well
he threw the football and really the big
adjustments they made mike and this it's
all about brady comfort it's all about
brady comfort
and we've talked about this a lot all
their big pass plays
are extra people in for pass protection
and really that's what they did in the
second half few the drop back pass game
they just said let's get the ball out of
our hand quickly if we're going to drop
back pass because we're having a hard
time with the speed of this atlanta
front they did play action passes and in
the first half where they did play
action passes and then he'd get back
there and wait for something to develop
in the second half it was a little bit
more of hey play action pass come up hey
it's a shorter shorter you know route
here boom hit it and then when they
wanted to take their shots downfield
like the bomb to a b which was a
perfectly thrown
50-yard laser that was nine feet off the
ground they kept gronkowski in the block
they got six blockers brady's
comfortable and when brady's comfortable
he still got a laser and that to me was
the big thing of the game but i'm still
not giving hope up on this buccaneers
football team i mean i i still wouldn't
be shocked if we were sitting here nfc
championship game sunday and we're going
tom brady and the bucks are playing blah
blah blah i i just think there's still a
lot of positives about this team i agree
with you completely this is a guy that
has played i think it was two full
seasons minimum of playoff games at
least 32 playoff games as of a couple of
years yeah right he's got a ton of
experience with the season riding on the
outcome of the game and there are other
guys in that locker room who have
playoff experience and there are veteran
players who may not have play of a
playoff experience per se but shaquille
barrett who was with the broncos when
they won super bowl 50 he said guys like
levante david even though they've never
played in the playoff game they get it
they understand that they know what it
takes to commence the process of
improving every week as you get closer
and closer to the postseason and they
recognize what is coming and i think
having a guy like brady around has a
tremendous
value
i just think at a certain point the
coaching staff just needs to get out of
the way and let it happen i just feel
like if anything they're getting in the
way of tom brady being tom brady
you know i i
it's definitely a little weird at times
there's no doubt i mean i i don't know
what to say either you're right i mean
it's just
i think they finally have figured it out
though i do
just the last few weeks i think they're
very close to really putting it together
the right way like even you know even
though the first half of the game this
past sunday wasn't good it wasn't like
some of the other first halves where
i've gone why are we in the shotgun and
throwing the ball every play like what
is going on it wasn't far off like i
said it was just like you know to bruce
erin's point they just didn't execute
quite as well as they would have liked
atlanta did some things to them i think
that caught them off guard and then once
they settled in okay they started
whooping butt and we're like an
unstoppable locomotive there but i i i i
do think even the first half struggle to
me was encouraging because at least the
approach i felt like was the right way
as compared to those other weeks where
you're going wait we're going to drop
back 50 times with brady at 43 years old
and you think he's going to carry the
team that's not realistic
this is this is better they're close
mike
saturday he returns to michigan for
likely the last time of his career to
face the lions
that one should be a win for the
buccaneers as they continue their march
toward the postseason then the falcons
come to town for week 17. they should
finish 11 and 5. i don't know what seed
that's going to get most likely five
which means they'll go to washington
washington right or new york or dallas
or philly all four of those teams still
alive for the nfc east crown in the home
playoff game that goes with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports